Alabama investigators suspect a fire  that destroyed the home of a woman who  accused Senate candidate Roy Moore of  sexual misconduct was intentionally set  however authorities do not believe there  is any indication the torching of the  home on Wednesday had anything to do  with the allegations it is all little  comfort to Tina Johnson it's too  coincidental to me but whatever they say  I'm I'll go with but you know right now  I'm just so devastated that I can't I'm  devastated  Johnson is among the women who publicly  accused War of sexual misconduct Moore  denied any wrongdoing but lost the race  to Democrats Doug Jones